bootleg cab show special guest in here
not only do we have a baby dinosaur
little c3 c3 your son is here who's also
moonlighting as a uh velociraptor
we have hit boy in here well so what's
up man that was good first of all uh i
mean just keep on congratulating you
every time i see you
[ __ ] just keeps leveling up and leveling
up
see the interviews going viral
man
trying to bro that j stone interview was
hard yeah i was i was actually thinking
about that i was like i wonder if
kendrick like showed the family or
whatever so that was the first thing i
thought that was good perspective yeah
cause i was like yeah i wonder when the
heart part five came out i was like
you know all the people's faces he used
i wonder if like everyone had a heads up
or i just was on some real artist [ __ ]
and just threw it out yeah and it worked
out because it was done with a great
intention and great you know
great artistic uh executed that [ __ ]
perfectly man what did you think of the
kendrick album
fire amazing yeah yeah yeah for sure
what is it like what you know
you obviously worked with kendrick in in
the past um
you've worked with like who's who's that
one artist that
creative process who you've been in the
studio with was like just different that
was like the most unique because you've
been in with everybody
i mean it's like i can't say because
everybody got their own unique you know
ways about them you know i'm saying like
working with somebody like big sean like
how he always
just makes sure he really dial in on
every lyric every line like he'll say
some [ __ ] and i'm like oh that's it it's
fire he'd be like nah i think i'd come
with something crazier so just even
watching artists just that that helps me
gain perspective helps me to want to
push further you know what i'm saying
have you taken any of the stuff you've
seen
on the producer side when you work with
artists and applied it to your [ __ ] as a
rapper
oh any of the creative stuff oh i'll be
sitting next to knives while he's what i
mean
that's what i'm saying engineered most
of the songs so i i literally
watched you know the way he's delivering
the lyrics the way he's writing them and
it's like i have no choice but to be
leveling up every time we link up so
you'll apply some of that stuff to your
own
one million percent yeah i wouldn't i'll
be stupid not to so corsa is uh
officially the the youtube premiere is
out yeah friday i think there's it's
gonna be on dsp dsp is thursday night
it's on youtube right now it's on
youtube right now dsps this week going
crazy man we got the merch course all
that yeah so give me because obviously
you and dom uh half a mill you guys
already have a great a great legacy uh
is this going into the direction of
another
joint project or what is what's going on
we just always we got a crazy just good
friendship just firstly so
the music is just becoming you know what
i'm saying and this was a joint we did
and we both agree like bro we gotta drop
this like [ __ ] different hold up boy we
talking on the radio i think he's trying
to get out of that mask
you want to take it off and he's trying
to figure that out you good
c3 you good buddy
that's bootleg cab dude
we're gonna eat you some chips man what
kind you want
yeah so you and dom you just are i mean
you guys are always working
always working and corsa was just
something we came up with and it just
felt right you know what i'm saying we
um
we took the song in new york i went to
brooklyn and uh i saw him went out to
bed-stuy and just played the joint like
it wasn't even like no forceful like oh
we about to record y'all let's like i
want y'all to dance to it they just was
dancing to that [ __ ] getting
sturdy
they was just doing it on their own yeah
it was fly yeah you know i saw i saw
they were doing the new york i don't
know what that dance called you know
what's that what's that called the video
today again sturdy getting started yeah
yeah the the drill the drill wave in new
york is crazy right now
um
so
i see you have a surf club chain on for
people who don't know that is kind of
the origins
of everything you kind of came into the
game uh shout out to uh the whole surf
club [ __ ] that whole movement was insane
is this something you're gonna be
resurrecting i mean it never went away
like surf club that's just been at the
core of everything i do but you know i
started cause it went it went yeah
what's that to surf club to hs87 yes
it's just like i feel like hs87 is like
my heart and soul of the music aspect of
what i do surf club is just the overall
lifestyle that's how i live my life just
so some awesome wavy [ __ ] like we've
been on that for years so
you know what i'm saying we i mean surf
club not to really i'm about to really
be putting out you know new music new
artists my own music just like really
pushing the lights through surf club
through the surf club so that is
officially gonna be like your label yeah
one million percent nice it's gang
though like everybody that's from surf
club they can do what they do with the
with the wave because we all started it
together
what uh
would there be any of the old hs87 guys
you try to like i always think about k
roosevelt and do me now and how perfect
of a song that was
and
it's crazy because i feel like you were
as as crazy as hs87 was somehow just the
timing wasn't right yeah i mean well
everything was changing with uh you know
dsps and you know going over from people
buying music to like completely
streaming and they were still trying to
calculate how to do all that so we got
kind of caught up in the whirlwind of of
that and i feel like not having the
right infrastructure not having the
right people
on my team speaking for me
while i'm making this music because it's
hard to make the music and have to think
about the business you have to think
about all the other aspects of
everything and you had you had a pretty
serious roster too like uh it wasn't
like you just had a couple of artists
you had audio push kent money
i forget what what was the young lady's
name tomorrow bmac b-mac
b-mac the queen you know okay roosevelt
i just like kind of just opened up you
know the opportunities i had opened up
the house of hit era the house of hit
area just just like um
opening up the studio opening up the
opportunities for everybody to just come
do their thing and it was a super uh
like a real learning curve for me just
like on how to really move in the game
and now you kind of are probably able to
take some of those lessons you learned
and then apply them to the surf club one
million percent how many years later is
this seven years
it's about hey
what's that twenty fourteen twenty
something almost nine years bro for real
well i mean we when was granted well
granted all my life was 2014 20 yeah so
damn eight that was eight years eight
years i remember hearing granny all my
life at least a year before it came out
yeah you used to pull up yeah that's
crazy and i remember when you told me
that that was your dad rapping i was
like wait a minute free big hit too man
free your pops man i remember that was
the wildest [ __ ] because when he was
like hit boys my son no i was like wait
wait
yes my pops
yeah shout out to your dad man free him
um
is there gonna be uh but i just wanna
thank you because
you are uh obviously nas has a lot to do
with it but just in terms of kind of
i don't know what it is about your
relationship with nas but it has
inspired him to release a high quantity
of music over the last couple of years
the fact we got magic just as like a
bonus last year was [ __ ] incredible i
think magic low-key might be my favorite
of the three albums that's the funny
thing and that's what's motivational for
me and i would say him as well is the
fact that every time we drop a project
people are like nah this one better than
the last one they've gotten better each
time exactly so my thing is like let's
just keep leveling it up every time and
kind of just competing with ourselves
we're not obviously nas is who he is
like he see he's cemented in this [ __ ]
and you know legend royalty all that but
it's like he just motivated to to make
the music and it's just strictly about
that and that's why it's just leveling
up how much of kings disease three is uh
has been worked on yeah i can't say a
percentage man but you guys it's it's
it's happening i mean you know he said
it don't imagine yeah i'm saying he said
it so it's on the white so it is on the
way
nice is it when you guys get in for a
new project is it is there any sort of
direction or is it just such an organic
vibe that it's like whatever comes out
comes out you guys guys that's basically
how it is like because we we just kept
recording after kd2 and
you know it was a moment where i was
like maybe this is kd3 and was like nah
we got to just go with a completely new
concept and he just was knocking him out
up until the point where he was like nah
we got to drop some you know two out 202
in one year that shit's big bro
and it's crazy too because like i know
you guys won uh
you got something to say
say what up
he's like i'm straight
i was gonna say uh you guys obviously
won uh grammy for rap album of the year
in 2021 right 2020. 2020. yeah [ __ ] the
whole last couple of years
everything is just oh man it's crazy
yeah but i feel like kings disease 2 was
the better album
of oh what exactly i mean that's how a
lot of people yeah so i feel like magic
is better than the last the other two
exactly so it's like that's why you
can't really call it man like you gotta
just
just keep it pushing after you know the
decision like even with my producer of
the year award i was going to say 20 20
you got you got snubbed 2021 it came
back around you got the nomination
that's the nomination you should've took
the award a lot of people have said that
but it is what it is you got to keep
pushing for that next year yeah what uh
who who ended up winning the year you
were nominated last year who won um
what was his name
bleachers
jack antonoff right yeah uh huh i mean
congrats to him for show i never met him
and then but but he ain't on a hit boy
run
let's be honest
i feel like you and alchemist loki have
had the craziest like underrated well
yours yours not as underrated but that's
like you and i have really been like nah
and alchemist is just pure
in terms of just putting out [ __ ]
non-stop the last few years there's just
quality yeah like i mean he was like
killing [ __ ] before i even ever made a
beat you know of course yeah that was
just ill to just that's motivation for
me it's like damn you could keep
leveling it up you can keep reaching new
heights and just making the [ __ ] that
you want to make you know what i love
was uh
when you guys did your verses you and
boy wondered during the pandemic it was
one of the early ones that was the first
one after swizz and uh timberland that's
right they didn't even set theirs up
they just got in the car bored during
the pandemic and started playing records
right they're saying ours was
you know set up it was people tuned in
and tapped into that it's crazy too
because it happened kind of like
pre the grammy pre
i think king's disease wasn't out yet
right now there was so much i was the
super underdog big time underdog big
time but i feel like during that verses
you just had to kind of remind people
like yo yeah that's why i was good and
that's what i loved about versus in the
early days is it was giving you know you
know flowers to the people that don't
normally get you know the flowers or
whatever so i feel like that that was
the aspect that was so ill to me and it
felt really organic there was something
about
it not being as
produced
when it was just like yo we're going
live we're in i'm in my spot you're in
your spot that [ __ ] made it intense yeah
i think it made it intense and i just
think it it introduced like a
unpredictability that like once they got
it like really together it was like yeah
it's like kind of watching the tv show
now yeah yeah for sure
for sure yeah it's super produced in
high level high quality there was
something about like you know uh yeah my
connection was yeah people trying to
figure out the sound like when rizza and
primo were trying to figure out like
yo yo yo no no try this try this it was
just something about that that
was like vintage versus like i didn't
even know the last uh
ball and mjg [ __ ] i didn't even know
that [ __ ] has going on when it was going
on i've seen people like yo i didn't
even know it was the verse is happening
right now yeah i think the last verses
that i was really honed in on was the
bone thugs one with three six okay just
because i'm a big bone fan and i just
wanted to see how that went that's
what's up and it was an entertaining one
because busy bone got extremely uh
emotional and uh
last big one i remember it was the gucci
and jeezy one that was probably the
was that uh was that before jadakiss you
know what was that after that was before
i was before so maybe he had a jada kiss
joining that was like the pinnacle yeah
i think the kiss moment is like the
greatest versus performance ever yeah
for sure i think jada um
it was the rawest hip-hop moment it's
the most raw [ __ ] cause he wanted versus
by just being like
like that freestyle he did was like it
was like dude like that's just rapping
no no no extras it was the epitome of
why we love hip-hop music like how we
grew up listening to this [ __ ]
it's like kiss just went up there and
put on a clinic like how to perform how
to just
like [ __ ] the hits he had the hits but
like just
yeah try to do this you guys are rapping
over your tracks over there
shout out to kiss man yeah for sure what
i also love is how you've just been kind
of bringing a lot of worlds together
sonically
um whether it's bringing blast into the
room with nas or having dom kennedy on a
record with like there's certain like
collaborations that probably never would
have happened and from like somebody who
loves west coast hip hop and just loves
hip hop in general
i'm like that's that's the hit boy sauce
like i'm not sure dom and nas would have
work together had
they not linked
oliver yeah like i just i just think of
it as music you know i'm saying i don't
really you know categorize [ __ ] i'm just
like if again if it can sound quality in
my head i know i can bring that out to
speakers yeah 100
um who are some of the younger artists
right now because you do have your ear
to the street your studio's kind of
become like a
it's a special place man um who are some
of the younger artists right now that
you're checking for that aren't on surf
club and then let's shout out the ones
who maybe
may or may not be on surf club yo what
up man we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good folks
at blue chew that's right go to
bluetooth.com fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
buchu it is the wave uh how about this
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis getting delivered right to
your door in a chewable form in discrete
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all
online zero awkward visits to the
doctor's office zero you go online you
sign up with the promo code bootleg
that's right bootleg when you check out
you will get the first month for free
all you gotta do is pay five dollars on
shipping and you're gonna get one
month's supply of blue chew all right
and you're gonna be [ __ ] like you
were [ __ ] never [ __ ] before your
dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and socked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com
and use that promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechew.com let's get back to the
interview i mean right now i'm playing
the homie spank nitty he uh he out he
out of the ie he ought to him it i
actually found that damn it yeah deep in
the eye that's why
my homeboy uh price from audio push
actually killing it put me on his music
you know i'm saying hi like a few years
ago shout out price who just uh i think
he's on tour with a big crit right now
he's doing his thing for sure so he put
me on spank music some years ago and
it's funny he used to be signing me and
now me and spank will be working on a
lot of music together
yo for people who don't know hammond is
a it's deep oh that [ __ ] it's very deep
like i mean it's like it's like breaking
bad [ __ ] up right up right over there
like close to coachella really yeah some
breaking bad [ __ ] going on in hemet for
sure yeah
yeah
damn so is it that someone you're
working with that's somebody i'm working
with somebody i just been building
making music with and i don't know
exactly where it's gonna go but we just
been trying to figure it out how long um
because somebody like i feel like uh you
and blas have
kind of similar parallels in terms of
like just you guys have been around for
a long time now blast finally got his
flowers recently but did you ever know
blast like
back in the day when he was producing he
was in a group he used to be in a group
forgot the name of the group but i know
the homegirl jizzle first introduced me
to blast he she brought him to my studio
and uh he was playing joints from his
group i believe at the time and she was
telling me how he kind of was like
creative directing his own [ __ ] so he
always had the vision that's one thing i
realized looking back you know watching
travis scott go from literally zero to
where he is now watching frank ocean not
even be an artist he was writing songs
to my beats you know saying not even
just to sell them to other people
just watching these people like they
also had a vision for themselves early
like travis he knew the type of videos
he wanted to make you know how he wanted
to dress how he wanted his hair i
remember seeing that that [ __ ] matters
travis opened up for casey veggies back
in the day like 2010 11 12. i don't
remember i remember what year it was but
yo it's crazy and then i didn't know so
frank you knew frank ocean prior to him
actually deciding to become an artist
one of his first placements ever was
this song that he wrote on a beat that
me and chasing cash did it was a song
for brandy that was on one of her items
and he wrote the song to it oh [ __ ] yeah
it's chasing the call first in love is
chasing cash going to be involved in the
obviously og surf club member is 16 like
he shot me the logo that i made my chain
out of and we're using that logo shout
out to his uh clothing line too i forget
what it's called but it's fire yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah crazy
shout out to the new orleans legend man
one million um
damn that's it's crazy how much history
you've been a part of though man you
know for sure i mean even like [ __ ]
drake repping surf club back in the day
you go listen to his emily freestyle he
shouted out surf club go listen to uh
9am in dallas he's shouting out surf
club and chase just like it's it's real
deep rooted so i just you know i'm
saying when we when we pop out just on
some [ __ ] people just gotta know it's
history to this 100
can you give me um
what is your best story because i i'm
real tight with uh
you know in phoenix we got a legend to
us and he is a legend up shout out my
brother lifted who produced mercy of
course yeah we used to be around each
other a lot out in hawaii you know right
so he would tell me some of these
stories about hawaii or even like some
of these hotel sessions up in like some
hotel suites out of london yeah in
london yeah yeah
like yeah i just flew in and just kanye
had the studio set up in a hotel suite i
remember we was all in there me lifted
push it was pretty much the whole roster
of good music and they played the mercy
beat and sean was literally sitting on
the floor everybody around him he just
like recording his verse like vibing
that [ __ ] was crazy kanye was like kind
of coaching him like it was a moment wow
yeah so he's just recording it in the
room just sitting on the floor holding
the mic on the floor like just going
over his parts that's crazy
there was another um song that i may or
may not have heard a snippet of that
never has seen the light of day that was
similar to mercy now i know they put out
a mercy part two that wasn't
crazy but there was another record that
i think was supposed to be what was the
other
cruel summer is the one we got then they
were supposed to be cruel winner right
winner yeah i mean i i still got a bunch
of beats in my uh zips
that say cruel winner ideas like i was
presenting ideas for crew winner because
i had three or four songs on cross
summer
that's crazy
did you hear any of the cruel winter
[ __ ]
um we just i mean probably probably
stuff that could have been on there
hey man you got a new dinosaur mask you
got to let them live jurassic park comes
out on friday right right right you're
going to go see it you want to see
jurassic park probably
um
how dope was it because i know that
there was like a um
i don't know like a weird uh energy
between you and yay and then it was dope
to see you guys kind of get back
together um
around the time that the donda kings
kings disease [ __ ] was happening um
really like uh linking up with game like
i linked up with him top of january and
we just started cutting
after we after like three days we
probably had like 11 12 joints and it
was a one joint in particular i was like
yo you need to have yay pull up the
chalice so we can get him on this joint
we end up playing a bunch of stuff and
easy was one of the ideas that game had
already had and as soon as uh
kanye had um heard the easy part he
tapped me like yo this like this the one
basically and how he ended up hopping on
it that was something that uh him and
the homie duke duke is fire dude crazy
straight you know saying shout out ohio
to homies
cleveland right from cleveland right
yeah hey hey relax dude also duke could
also be he's also a security slash
producer that guy's that guy's a
mountain of a man yeah i've been knowing
duke for a minute yeah he's he's an
incredible producer so
what's up man we got something to say
what up how old are you do you know
you know
it's okay the kids are shy man my kid
was shy when he was up until he was like
six
um
yeah these game sessions were crazy
because i remember going to um listen to
like he invited me to the studio
and
it was you know we know how studio
sessions are and they're not like how
people think they are yeah like you know
if you tell your girl you're going to
the studio and she doesn't know better
she's going to think there's a bunch of
hoes and a bunch of [ __ ] going on
yeah and it's not like that right well
these sessions were definitely like that
there are they are 100 rapper sessions
it was some real vintage i call it club
games it was club [ __ ] it's a whole
bottle it's a bar
but the crazy thing is is he's in there
knocking out four or five songs a
nightmare he's in there focused it's
crazy no matter what's going on never
have 100 people in my session and get
all this done so i mean applaud to him
and just i think it's crazy how many uh
beats do you have on the dramatic
project that's coming out on the 17th oh
no cause i know they trying to clear
samples and i don't know what's gonna
clear what's not we use a bunch of
samples so we're gonna see was that like
uh
you you and game did you guys ever work
together previously yeah i worked on the
red um okay yeah i did some [ __ ] on
there so we always was tapped in and we
we we had other joints but just nothing
that ever came out and then uh we just
tapped in top of the year right after
magic came out it was just an energy in
the air so he pulled up and at first it
was just like us just in the stool
for you know three four days and we
knocked out a bunch of stuff and after
that he got inspired and he was like man
i'm about to start booking my own room
and he just turned it in the club yeah
he booked that room across from you yeah
actually it's crazy oh you want some
chips
you want some chips man
you want hey i have two phones you want
to play on one of them you want to watch
youtube
you want to i what kind of kid [ __ ] do i
have on my phone this this is the good
phone so there ain't nothing crazy on
here
do you want you want to uh you want to
play a game
he's like
what the [ __ ] man
we're gonna be like i'm crazy who is
this white man
um
yeah no it was i feel like because uh
game had played me some [ __ ] probably
like late last year this is before he
started working at chalice and he had
like what i guess he considered his
album
some of it was dope
um
but then the [ __ ] that he was working on
at chalice was just crazy it was like a
whole new energy i can't even tell you
how many songs he got because i know
just between me and him we got about 30
something songs so i'm like he didn't
had 100 producers in here he must have
two 300 songs like yeah really go like
that so once kanye pulled up to cut his
because we all saw the footage of him at
the studio was that like where you guys
kind of really had like a a moment to
kind of move past whatever energy had
been
i mean yeah at least for that moment for
sure it was dope like um i was able to
after you know we was in game room i was
like bro you got to come into my room
and just bless the energy like you know
nipsey been in there and i was getting
there so many people i'm like i gotta
have you pull up and he pulled up i was
able to play him a couple beats and we
was vibing but we haven't connected on
anything else yet was this prior or
after the uh the random drink champs
interview happened this was before
because then that interview happened and
sean's like i was just with this dude
like you know how that went down though
it's crazy you're gonna be able to edit
all yeah
so yeah that was the that was the funny
part for me because
how that thing went down was i reached
out to somebody that you know kanye was
rocking with this was around maybe
maybe october mm-hmm and i was like yo
me and sean got this song called what a
life we drop in and i want to see if
yeah uh hop on the remix so his people
was like yo
you know i reached out to him yeah it's
open to the idea but he wants to chop it
with you and sean come to sunday service
so we pull up the sunday service
it's all love we chopping it i'm telling
him and sean like yo we need to do click
part two it's a vibe whatever whatever
yeah and then um you know a few days
later the joint come out and i was just
confused as to how like he had already
recorded the drink champs but
we are in his face and he's not saying
nothing so it's just like that just
threw me off yeah sometimes uh drink
champs
you know i know sometimes they'll hold
interviews for like a month
i figured that's what happened i'm like
this had to have been recorded like a
few weeks ago or something i mean i
think it was just like recorded like
some days or like a week prior to you
guys actually thinking
so that just kind of hit y'all like what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so it's like you
know but it's all love though man yes
they chopped it they talked it out
that's good um something that you've
because i i whenever i have producers on
some chips
you want some chips bro
yeah
oh god
something that um
i just talked to south side about we
just talked to hitmaker about i try to
like
give game to
up-and-coming songwriters producers
and something that you've been vocal
about is your uh your pub deal yeah and
um it is a mistake that a lot of artists
make
uh
not even producers just writers um
signing a pub deal too early and getting
taken advantage of one million percent i
mean i would say you know i've spoke on
this in a bunch of interviews and i
don't want to get too deep right now but
i would just say that any deal period
make sure it's an exit plan make sure
that they can't you know it's like my
pop's been in prison in the system since
he was like 19 years old he's like 50
something now so it's like they'll
railroad you and they'll find loopholes
in ways to just keep you down keep you
in and i feel like i'm literally going
through that like no matter how much
money i earn or how much success i have
they don't really have to honor it
because of the way the the contract was
written yeah so it's like make sure you
got an exit plan that's that's the most
have you tried buying yourself out of
the deal oh they won't even let it
happen it's that's that deep it's like
it's sticky that's crazy just keep
airing them out bro because that's
that's why i got to go crazy that's
[ __ ] wild because you say you've been
in it since you were 19. yeah bro just
turned 35.
i've been in 19 16 years that's so crazy
[Music]
i don't know if like it's uh
acceptable anymore to offer those kind
of deals anymore because i know that
they have not well from right here like
they've gotten rid of the uh and was it
the mbrcs
because that's that minimum deliver the
delivery requirement i think where
they'll tell you
um
ten compositions yeah but that's that's
that's a thousand points yeah so if you
do a beat what would you say hit like if
you do a beat
it's like a typical amount of points you
would get on a record like not even you
specifically just in general your
experience in the music industry if you
make the beat i mean if you got you know
a good team and you got that leverage i
would say four maybe five points
sometimes per record per song
yeah and so yeah so if you have uh a
thousand points you have to recoup do
the math that's insane that's a lot so
how about this if somebody because you
know a lot of times uh somebody like
yourself a established producer
will reach out and maybe get a loop pack
from somebody i'm not saying you do that
but i mean in general like you know
sometimes
a nice way to get on if you're up and
coming artists is to send loops out yeah
like if you're up and coming
if uh
someone uses your loop was that
something that
what what what is ideally what did you
even get cut in on the pub at that point
i mean yeah i mean it just depends on
what y'all work out right or if they
have a set thing like oh this is this is
this is these are my terms or whatever
but most of the times it's like you know
it depends on how much they do like i'm
a super fair guy a lot of people like
even my counselor i've been like yo you
was you was like you were super fair
person like it's people that take
people's whole beats and don't even give
them and just throw the tag on it you
know what i'm saying like i see that
[ __ ] a lot yeah yeah no it's crazy i
mean it's happened a lot i mean
throughout hip-hop that's happened for
sure like no i made that beat but you
your tags on it i've seen interviews
about legendary producers that i that i
you know literally look up to that's
like nah this person really made that
beat so it's like
you know yeah hitmaker just shared a
story about
a big producer that just took the whole
song that he brought to them and then
got an ascap award for it and he was
sitting there collecting his own ascap
award and he's like the [ __ ] man
crazy man let's get past this part yes
i'll start getting deep
i better have it cause i thought that
[ __ ] do that i thought hitmaker would
take [ __ ] beats and songs like i don't
know she never heard him no no so i
asked him that i kind of had talked to
him about um
and he said you know yeah i bring people
together and they get their credit they
get their pub i look at him as like uh
like a khalid like an executive like
some mayonnaise he may not be actually
making the music but he knows how to
point out the right muscle you know what
he was saying he's like i cut everybody
in i have a song deal with atlantic and
somebody he said i have half of the
money smart business half of the money
that's allocated to me
i set aside half of it for the
co-producers for the co-writers and they
get all their credit business man for
sure i respect him on the business end
for sure for sure i mean you're in there
with the f i mean i've seen you're a
[ __ ] monster
how um like i was gonna say like how
much has your beat making process
changed over the years because there's
been so
i mean some people started on fruity
loops and then they've evolved to pro
tools or to
reason or like what is like your current
beat making
go-to setup what are you what are you
what are you cooking on i've been on fl
studio since 2003 bro almost 20 years
still yeah i mean i've messed around
with ableton logic yeah i use pro tools
i record and sometimes arrange my beats
in there but i'm fl studio but i'm just
quick on it
and shout out to uh ninth wonder who was
the first guy to really put on the first
time really heard about somebody super
professional make uh using fl yeah so
it's still fruity loops so you got to
have a pc yeah let me know they got it
on mac now do they i didn't know i know
back in the day you had to like
partition your hard drive that's what i
used to do yeah yeah i use a pc though
that's fire so you still use the pc
i use the aces yeah so you got your you
got your mac i'm sure everyone's got a
macbook for other [ __ ] and then you got
your i just got the mac the computer to
just put my pro tools stuff on i don't
even have a macbook no more that was
that was just what's up
you know he's just the kid hanging out
he's he he don't know he would like the
radio
anything now
anything you want to add age
tell them how old you are real quick
say it on the microphone how old are you
bro
oh man how is he two two yeah that's a
good just say two
say two chuck the deuce man
um
how many kids do you have that's my only
kid there's only one one of one
c3 man
i like it c3 what is the uh
he's the third so your dad's the first
you're the second he's the third that's
fire do you get to take him to go visit
grandpa like when he's locked up he was
born like literally a day before we went
into lockdown in l.a so he it was like
he's a covey baby you know saying kobe
baby you know you can't have really you
know visits in prison right going to
cover [ __ ] so yeah we're going to work
it out soon though hey um so
nowadays what i like about hello
um you have a team around you you got a
guy like jansport jay yeah who's been
around for a long time as an artist too
i remember seeing his [ __ ] on two dope
boys back in the day that's covina six
two six man um how important is it to
kind of like make sure you also surround
yourself or with
just like other inspiring producers guys
who bring
something to the table you know what i
mean sure or not i mean
jan sport legendary like he chopped
samples like you know bar none like he's
one of the craziest doing that you know
i'm saying and that's just something
that inspired me like i definitely got
to keep myself surrounded with
you know people that are just
you know in their own land and just
doing what they do
yeah
how uh because you know with with you
for people who don't know you have a
studio at chalice that you've had for
what four years three years about to be
four years in august that's where you
did racks in the middle right
racks in the middle i did a bunch of
stuff all night all of the nice [ __ ] one
kd2 magic
um yeah it's just it's a special place
man um crazy we did burden the proof at
challenge too
i think i was i was there for that yeah
i was there for some of that [ __ ] conway
was there
yeah it's crazy west side gun it was a
yeah hey and unofficially the start of
the album we're never going to get the
freddie gibbs benny album that's
probably never coming out i hope it does
man if not we will leak we're gonna well
you already kind of leaked it well i put
it on my ig one day i was just playing
and i'm like this [ __ ] too hard people
gotta hear this
yeah they leaked it on my joint you took
it down though i took it down did
anybody hit you about it i did get hit
up for sure it wasn't even like take it
down i just was like i'm gonna just take
it who hit you up about it
a couple people trouble people yeah
yeah from both sides yeah like yo what
the [ __ ] i thought about doing the same
thing i'm glad it was you though because
you made it i was like i can't do this
yeah and i was just like this be crazy
this song is insane mclovin hopefully it
comes out one day man maybe if you do
like a like it's on youtube and all that
for the show oh is it i mean just like a
league oh just your version that you put
you put up not the whole thing yeah
and maybe if you ever put out like a
producer compilation well that's what's
coming next like i'm actually starting
to drop music this summer i'm gonna drop
my first drink probably august it's
gonna be just like my beats with
different artists without you rapping
mm-hmm and i'm also dropping the rap
[ __ ] at the same time so doubling up the
flesh yeah how how like i feel like um
for somehow over the last five or six
years like you're still kind of been
flying under the radar
for some of the projects you put out as
a rapper
do you feel like finally that tide is
starting to turn in terms of like you
getting a lot more respect as an emcee
because you put out some great great
[ __ ] not even like dom [ __ ] aside like
half a mil [ __ ] aside like even the solo
[ __ ] you were putting up no i mean i
just feel like i just feel it on a
personal level you know and then when i
play the music i show the new videos i'm
making i just see the reaction you know
i'm saying a natural organic reaction to
the people that i played it for i'm like
yeah i definitely can see the growth i
can see what's up
i can see how much just being around
these great artists like big sean like
nas
what dude you don't want me to talk
yeah you want to put this on
dinosaur mode
there you go oh he's outside okay
um yeah just like seeing my own growth
man that's been super inspiring to me
beyond just like if other people are
hearing it as well it's just like damn
like i can i could just feel the growth
yeah yeah uh with this new [ __ ] that's
coming out obviously corsa
um
is there going to be
what is
is this the lead into like another
project a full project
or is this just kind of like most
definitely is
it's okay man we're here people see it
on youtube yeah yeah there's a we have a
two-year-old with a toy right it happens
um
damn ass asked me that one more i was
saying like uh with corsa like what is
this leading into like like corsa that's
um
it's gonna either end up on a half a mil
project or a solo headboard or whatever
the case is we're just making music at
this point you know i just want to keep
dropping keep the momentum up yeah 100
and that i know you recently uh left
rock nation right on a management level
on the management side um what what's
something that you had kind of learned
on
like
obviously rock nation is a prestigious
brand
all respect to them shout out to ho
shout out to everybody over there hey
everybody that locked in with me were
you able to like kind of like uh learn
anything of your time over there on the
management side just getting managed by
those guys yeah for sure and just like
on a personal level just the things that
i see from myself and the things that i
want for myself they have to align all
across the board and it's like if it's
any disconnection
it's going to be tough you know i'm
saying i want to get into the details of
you know nothing but it's all love to
them that's fire what is uh
you know we've seen a lot of producers
do different business moves outside of
music are you working on anything that
is not necessarily directly music
related i got the hitboy lg with the
homies illacanis you know what i'm
saying so you got some weed yeah i got
it in some stores right now some
lemonades and some cookie stores and
about to keep pushing it you know do you
actually like pull up and like go to the
grow and like figure out exactly what
your strain is going to be you've been
to the grove plenty times and then
sometimes they'll bring like even their
lab person to the studio just oh i've
been there and there's been pounds and
pounds of weed
i don't even know if it's that guy but
there's just yeah so they'll bring like
you know their whole team to the stool
and just vibe out with me and bring me
different strains to you know piece
together that we can
you know but you're a og guy
hit boy og is the overall brand waiting
game is the strange so this is like the
first one waiting game is not the most
heavy og you know smoke yeah but it's a
good smoke at the same time but the next
ones we're going to definitely hit them
with some og's
um
i remember being there one night and
there was like a jeweler who was trying
to rip everybody off yeah big sean was
there yeah
i gonna say his name i forget who it was
but there was like a jeweler who like
pulled and i it's funny because i've
seen that actually happen a bunch of
times where a jeweler
this was the jeweler that
you know the little baby when little
baby was like somebody showed me a fake
watch this is the same jeweler that was
at my studio i remember everybody once
he left was like yo this guy was really
trying to get over on us like he's
[ __ ] crazy
wow
but you know it's it's wow that's they
got the
they some of the illest finesses
everywhere you can think about it it
happens a lot i'm sure you've seen a
jeweler pull up to the studio prior like
that [ __ ] happens all the time where
somebody will pull up with a [ __ ]
suitcase of ice
in a room full of rappers there's no way
to verify if the [ __ ] is official and
then they'll try to upsell you like it's
like they're selling like you know when
you get a little kid knocking on your
door trying to sell you some candy or
some [ __ ] it's like
like in the towel lately
it's candy dudes outside of tao every
night like trying to sell you candy like
outside a highlight room really yeah
it's deep get in the bag it's like they
must have learned from the atlanta water
boys like why are we hanging out at
walmart why are we hanging out at target
let's go to the [ __ ] word let's go to
where all the famous people are let's go
sell some [ __ ] candy to paparazzi for
sure
what up y'all hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our partners
the presenting sponsor of the bootleg
podcast our family at odd socks man
they're dropping so much heat at odd
socks right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass
remember oddssoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
checkout let's get back to the podcast
have you uh had a like a little harder
time because i feel like your profile is
higher now than it's ever been in your
career
does it kind of change
how you move have you noticed like maybe
you gotta have security now
in places maybe you didn't have to have
it before [ __ ] getting robbed for this
[ __ ] and this [ __ ] all day around l.a
not just l.a but you know what i'm
saying it's like heavy out here it's
heavy you know you gotta just move
properly and i'll be having my son with
me like you don't want to just get
caught up in any just situation being
too
just all over the place so i moved
militant regardless yeah that's
important why do you think that is in la
man do you like because it is a thing in
la i think i think a lot of it was
because the edd was rampant out here
that [ __ ] dried up people got to see
something they ain't ever seen and be in
places ain't never been and it's like
hard to let that go so it's like anybody
by any means so you just got to be
moving right you are somebody who took
the pandemic and like leveled up to a i
think a career high i did the same thing
what was a
w was was it a coincidence for you that
the pandemic like worked out for you in
the right way or was there something
that happened during the pandemic where
you kind of had a switch turn on because
it kind of for me like i said this guy
was born a day before the lockdown so i
was like nah i gotta i gotta go into
overdrive like i was already feeling
that way like knowing he was coming when
he got here it was like nah bro it's a
game changer i gotta kill [ __ ] and go to
a new level
yeah once you have a kid man it changes
everything yeah a hundred percent say
something new
how old are you say oh two
say what up the bootleg k he's shy man
he's a shy little guy i'm mad at you bro
i'm gonna get you some chips in a little
bit
at least you don't have an ipad you know
most kids you get the ipad you're like
nah for sure i mean he'd be having an
iphone he don't even like the ipad he
got an ipad and he got his own little
cell phone and he'd be using him a lot
of kids are getting raised by ipads
these days oh for sure yeah i'm gonna
tell you this my son millennium he's
eight years old
sometimes
he'll have youtube going on the big tv
downstairs and i'm like the [ __ ] are you
bruh
the [ __ ] are you watching like
maybe into these uh
what's the uh
mr beast and
i mean he's still on like blippi and
like real little kids yeah the blippi
[ __ ] is lit i don't even know about it
bro when he was born like you know
that's when i first was watching blippi
come up and then
like last week i'm going through like
the netflix he's on hbo max he's got a
new movie on hbo has like his own
cartoon now it's crazy right yeah the
blippi thing is why it really came what
yeah yeah it's crazy because i remember
as a kid like
there was like teletubbies and mm-hmm
yeah blippi's that guy right now for the
kids and that little asian kid ryan
ryan's toy review ryan ryan's world yeah
right right that kid who yo his his
parents are eating
he's like nine what's he doing with a
hundred million dollars his parents like
that's us right
you just need to get him open at toys on
youtube nah for sure
that's coming
yeah that's a that's a revenue stream
for sure for sure what else uh obviously
beside your solo [ __ ] i'm sure you got a
lot of placements coming i know you
can't divulge into all of those but yeah
i've been i've been tapped in man the
hip's working i'm uh i'm actually
working on a lot of music for the new
madness dropping fire the one with
madden on the cover uh huh yeah i'm
doing a lot of like the scoring for like
the franchise mode like when you're
doing the career mode like i'm basically
all the scenes like i'm scoring them so
you're scoring them with all original
[ __ ] original music yeah that's big is
this the first time you've scored
something like nah i scored a movie
caught on court that was on netflix
oh the guy that's actually the black
dude that's and i can't think of his
name he's in the new jurassic park
that's coming out on friday that was one
of his first big roles and uh i scored
that whole movie and
did a couple other things but this is
like you know when you score something
like that do they send you those scenes
dry and then it's just up to you to set
the vibe they'll send well they'll send
me a reference that they might have you
know picked a song or picked a piece of
music that they thought fit so they was
like try to like at least match the
energy it is like do your own thing but
try to just make sure it has a pace
similar to how this is moving wow that's
big so you're kind of i did when when
are are you gonna you're gonna get
credit on matt it's probably gonna be
like
executive produced by hitboy
um somebody who i love that's young
that's up and coming
he's from the bay but he's in la have
you got a chance to work with simba yet
i have not but i mean i didn't seen him
tear down a few freestyles he's crazy
duke working with him yeah duke works
with him yeah i feel like you guys got
to set up a session well we had set up a
session but this was maybe a couple
years ago and timing is everything he's
special man yeah uh so the game album we
don't know how many you have but
hopefully we'll find out on the 17th no
i guess we all gonna find out because
that's like next week right right i feel
like game is very very sporadic he's
coming on the show next week so i'm
gonna but yeah it's like 30 songs and
next week or you know it's like that's a
crazy guy but he's he's a great rapper
man so you know let him just do what he
do he is a great rapper and he's got
one of the more
prestigious
discographies
yeah especially on the west coast too
because game don't put out whack albums
yeah for sure like i can't think of a
time where i listened to a game album
and i was like
it's like solid always i feel like he's
and i feel like not a lot of people can
say that everyone has weak points in
their discography i'm not sure game has
any because red album was dope [ __ ]
uh the jesus piece the obviously
doctor's advocate was my favorite yeah
i'm trying to think lax lax was fine
that album was crazy documentary two was
dope um a lot of bars are you are you
and benny gonna do burden of proof too
we're gonna see
i wanna tap back in woody
that was uh just working with jay worthy
the other day he uh we all tapped in on
a text message like a group text we want
to do something together so we're going
to put it together i feel like that's
kind of his illmatic low-key
crazy that's a crazy way to put it yeah
i mean it kind of changed his life and
that and you know a lot of people would
say that's his best body of work it
would only be right
would you do another joint album with um
you know because you and conway's [ __ ]
is was crazy man that's somebody i was
thinking like man we might as well just
crank one out and do it out of me and
conway i think that should be hard yeah
cause
conway's that guy that [ __ ] with him and
dave's love that i did was hard oh
that's
that was the first song on the album the
intro yeah that was
yeah did you are you the one who put
dave's wolf on that record that was
conway yeah
because actually it came out crazy yeah
yeah shout out to the griselda guys um
anything else that you're working on man
what else should i bring up
guys who with me every day
that's a lot of [ __ ] courses on dsps
friday right uh there's no music man i'm
dropping a lot of rap [ __ ] and i'm
dropping a lot of production all at the
same time is your production album
compilation joint is that already kind
of like do you have like a folder where
there's already [ __ ] in there set aside
i got a lot of joints different artists
but you know it's clearances and it's a
lot of nuances that go into it i'm going
to go out on a ledge and say nas and dom
kennedy might be on that album
that's a good guess
that's an easy one and then kings
disease 3 hopefully i'm working on an
album with belly too belly are you
serious got some [ __ ] we i'm pretty much
done we got some crazy joints dude hip
hop and some turnt up [ __ ] belly is
one of my favorite rappers
just period and he's like my shroom
brother me and him are very much into
the into the shrooms
has belly try to get you to eat rooms
yet
now billy ain't uh
i mean a lot of people have been talking
about shrooms lately but that's not my
thing but he does cook a crazy meal a
crazy
tenderloin with these noodles bro
he's such a prolific emcee
so prolific on that pen
did have you been in the studio with him
he has this thing at his house it's like
a plate uh with sand on it
and
i know you got a few houses or something
no no no so there's this like thing it's
uh there's a name for it
and it's like a plate that has a bunch
of sand on it and it makes shapes
um the music that you play whatever
frequency or whatever yeah the sand
moves into like the shapes of
you see that it's crazy you gotta ask
him about that [ __ ]
so you and belly got a whole album
coming
yeah [ __ ]
i gotta pull up on belly and hear this
[ __ ] what did you guys record it at his
house your place we recorded it at my
spot in his spot yeah he got a crazy
studio yeah he's actually um the
producer cb wit too uh it's a duo i
forget their names man but they're super
talented i would i [ __ ] i wish i
remember their names you probably met
the guys the two guys he's got with him
you talking about the homies from exo
yeah yeah yeah
and he's got a very moody french bulldog
chips have been secured
the chips have been secured so belly
album
kings disease three hopefully
yeah yeah we you know that's a tough one
bro because it's the first time we got
some real pressure on us we got so much
lead time before
you really only had like seven days to
prepare for kd one five days to prepare
for kd2 and then magic we dropped the
cover 12 hours before no magic [ __ ] came
out out of nowhere it was like a 12
hours we dropped the artwork maybe 12
p.m and it dropped at 12 a.m so we we
just the longest like because he's he he
said this you know on the song ugly kd3
on the way
this is real like it's pressure this
[ __ ] got to be hard it gotta be and it's
the trilogy what's the trilogy there
hasn't been any i mean shout out to the
blueprint right there's three of those
there were some weak points in the
blueprint i mean i would i wasn't crazy
about blueprint three to be honest but
blueprint2 had some of my favorite hoef
now there was some fat that they cut off
when they did the blueprint 2.1 you
remember that
they put out like the original blueprint
too
and then there was this i never knew
what that was about because it was just
because there were there was some good
[ __ ] on the blueprint too like some of
my favorite i think the best
storytelling song ever is on there it's
called meet the parents oh yeah that's a
classic record song but there was a lot
of [ __ ] on blueprint blueprint too
so they're the 2.1 i feel like it was
kind of like
because i always used to see that cover
because they had the red with the white
one split up yeah i just never knew what
i was i think it was just like all right
guys we
i think it was their way of trying to
get people to really digest the fire
[ __ ] on that album
but you guys are two for two three for
three but you know
kings disease three you got you're right
okay three gotta you gotta be the one do
you feel like the way you and nas work
together like this is just for life now
i mean
i was i mean cuz i would hate like kings
disease three come out and then that guy
cool we completed the trilogy we're
moving on you never know bro honestly we
just kind of just move off the energy
that's present with us and
it just seemed like it's going to be
going for a while so let's just hope for
that who who do you think you have
similar chemistry with i would say sean
i would say dumb i actually got a great
[ __ ] uh
rapport with don toliver like
you know i did a single his first single
on his last album what you need and um
we working on new music now and it's
like me and bro got a synergy
you know i love don toliver because uh
his voice to me is just very
just like there's very few people who
have like that unique pitch that's
they're like when you hear him you hear
him
you know who it is
is he still managed by cheddar connect i
would not know bro remember the flick of
the wrist song yeah from what i
understood for a while that was his
manager which is amazing because that
song was south by southwest 2014
encapsulated is flick of the wrist yeah
yeah did you ever do a south by run oh
yeah you came to my stage and performed
i used to go to
man i was going there way before even
[ __ ] was even a little popping yeah no
the uh my first big stage there you guys
performed well do you remember that it
was you guys audio push
uh wiz khalifa burner and ty performed
crazy
damn you know them runs used to be like
you just going down you do like 12 shows
yes
i went to south by uh this year for the
first time since like 2016 and it was
god awful overall i would never bro
don't go what was it it's a waste what
was different about it just there's no
energy
there's it's it's terrible like you know
you used to go to south by it was a
thing it was a thing and you'd also be
like
oh i got to check out this person
because they're on the cusp
you know what i mean
there was none of that this year it was
it was the first year back post pandemic
but it was absolutely disappointing i
was like i was trying to tell the homies
that were out there with me for the i
was like this just so y'all know this
ain't how it usually is this [ __ ]
used to be legendary
um cool man and then [ __ ] you got to
start djing man what are you talking to
south side south side is going to start
djing you got to start djing yeah man
[ __ ] get all the bags
the little gig i did like when i really
dj like they paid me great so i'm with
all that you just play you know edwards
and paris and all the hits played out
about ten times and then
i was gonna say peak
in paris
how many times in a row did they end up
what was the record on the watch the
throne tour they did it back to back to
back i feel like it's like 15 14 15 in a
row yeah and in the club you could play
that [ __ ] five times just back to back
i don't even remember the last time that
happened
it hasn't as far as i know
there's been big club records like i
remember like designers panda was like a
[ __ ] moment but like nothing that you
could just
rewind over and over and over especially
in a concert
oh yeah the show [ __ ] was crazy and then
you i remember you got pulled up on
stage in one of those shows that was a
show in paris
yeah that was
that was it
didn't you have that framed or something
mature yeah i got that on the canvas
somebody got that done for me where do
you keep your grammys these days right
in the studio right where i'm making
beats they be right there don't keep any
at home any at the mom's house nothing
nah i'm gonna get some more and then
i'll give them to her can you order
extras
no
they just give you the one yeah if it's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] right damn
all the how many grammys now
three now three it's a lot of grammys
man that's you know there's people out
here with 20 something man so i got work
to do and these people out here with
zero
you are right about that
you have more than us
that's crazy yeah that's nuts you have
two more than knowledge right yeah i
can't say the one we got together that's
you know what's crazy as i felt like nas
was like up until he got his grammy it
was like leonardo dicaprio at the oscars
like leo has this one of the greatest
actors of all time yeah and up until uh
what was the movie with the bear that
[ __ ] him up do you remember the name
of that movie nema
revenant he finally got right right he
finally got one
it's like dude yeah this is an all-time
great tupac ain't got no grammy big i
don't think i know grammy a lot of
people don't man so which one means the
most the nipsy grammy or the nas grammy
that's a great question
they both
they both mean a whole lot honestly i
feel like the energy that nipsey left
with me and left in my room just because
he loved working in my studio so much
that trickled down into katie i don't
think there would be a katie you know
because
just the amount of energy in the way i
feel when i'm in the room and the way
that other artists feel they want to
work they got a real
spirit of wanting to get [ __ ] done when
they pull up
i don't think the kd [ __ ]
is i think it has something to do with
nick you know i don't wanna know super
spiritual or no weird or whatever but i
definitely think he left an energy there
for me and us to really because him and
nas had just linked up before it
happened obviously me and nip was
working a lot so it was just something
that just tells me like
that energy was left in there for me and
nas to get them albums done
nipsey was obviously a one-of-one
is there anyone in the game right now
that gives you similar energy that nip
that nip had
i can't call it right now i can't really
think of nobody right it was very like
lightning in a bottle
it's crazy for sure one on one for sure
man yeah
what's um for you man uh you know if we
watch this in 20 years
what do you want the legacy of
hip boy to be
and you might still be [ __ ] active in
20 years let's say we watched it in 35
years 40 years you're retired what is
what do you want the legacy of hitboy to
be man um
i'ma just say like
just being associated with great [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying the way i look
at the people who came before me like i
just want people to look at me the same
way like man this [ __ ] was
really on that music [ __ ] really like
going crazy
i think you're very much like knocking
so you know when we always ask like
who's the greatest producers of all time
there's always the names that nobody can
say [ __ ] about i think it's dj premier
it's dr dre it's timbaland uh
rizza
you know i mean even alchemist is in
that conversation but there's
there's like that i feel like you're
like right you're
i think you're
i mean you're there you're getting there
you're getting into that conversation
that not a lot of people
like a very elite club of all time
greats
i mean you know that's honestly
something i it's not really up to me
it's just about me putting in the work
putting in the time
to be considered on that level
yeah i think you're up there man i think
like
in terms of just quality of beats i'm
not sure anybody can [ __ ] with you i've
always told you this anytime you've ever
just like played beats as long as i've
known you
dude
i've never had anybody ever just play me
beats that just like
stand alone by themselves in such an
amazing way so shout out to you man uh
corsa out course out right now new [ __ ]
on the way yes sir go by there's the
merch available merch is available on
hitboy.com surf club [ __ ] coming yeah
there it is man go buy some hitboy og
yes sir and uh yeah and shout out to
your son who brought it amazing he's
somewhere right over here there it is
man hit boy
fire